in Georgia the governor is poised to
sign one of the most restrictive
anti-abortion laws in the country state
lawmakers narrowly passed a measure
Friday that would outlaw most abortions
once a heartbeat can be detected in the
embryo the ACLU says it will sue to
block the legislation
Marco Morgan is at the Georgia Capitol
in Atlanta DeMarco good morning John
good morning to you the bill is
officially known as the Life Act which
stands for living infants fairness and
equality but it's also unofficially
known as the fetal heartbeat bill and it
has thrust George into the middle of a
national controversy which could end up
at the US Supreme Court protesters
rallied at the Georgia Statehouse as
opponents came up just two votes short
of defeating the controversial abortion
ban the bill is now headed to the desk
of Georgia's governor Brian Kemp
it makes abortions illegal once a fetal
heartbeat is detectable as early as six
weeks after conception before many women
even know they are pregnant
state representative ed Setzler is the
bill's main sponsor we've established
their child in utero that has a beating
heart is a living distinct person that
gets full legal rights under Georgia law
the bill gives a fetus natural person
status which allows the fetus to be
entitled to child support claimed as a
dependent on tax returns and included in
Georgia's population abortions will be
allowed only if the fetus has a fatal
deformity the mother's life is
endangered or in rape and incest cases
where a police report was filed every
single doctor in this state has said
this is bad and the reason it's bad is
because it actually criminalizes care
and treatment that a doctor is required
to give State Senator ginger tern urged
her colleagues to vote against the bill
even revealing the agony of her eight
miscarriages God chose women alone to be
the fiduciaries of life not government
not this body
fetal heartbeat Bills have also been
introduced in four more states judges
have already blocked
similar laws in four states we've
listened to the court in the Roe versus
Wade decision that said if a state ever
establishes the personhood of the end
child all the logic of Ruby weight
collapses now Hollywood is threatening
to boycott Georgia if this bill becomes
law at least 85 stars have signed a
letter saying they'll take their
business elsewhere you may remember that
Black Panther also the Avengers and
stranger things and the walking dead
have all been filmed here in Georgia nor
now this story is not over DeMarco thank
you